im internet auf instagram und tik tok
kennen sie millionen menschen als konya
pranger schönes mädchen in der sprache
des indigenen volkes der tattoo you
gregor ist in florenz herren und zeigt
der welt ihren alltag im regenwald heute
will sie ein video aufnehmen indem sie
ameisen ist dies tradition ist bei ihrem
dorf ich nehme mir eine einzelne ameise
um sie zu essen
die ameisen sind gekochte und geräuchert
der geschmack erinnert sie an popcorn
doch es geht um mehr als um einen snack
gregor will ihren zuschauern indigene
philosophie vermitteln die im umgang mit
der natur immer eine rolle spielt
erst wenn wir die eine aufgegessen haben
essen wir die nächste wenn du viele auf
einmal ist und danach einen streit hast
dann bekommst du mit ganz vielen
menschen krach wenn du aber nur eine ist
dann wird dir nichts passieren
gregor ist ein star im netz mehr als
sechs millionen menschen folgen ihr
allein auf tik tok ihre mission ist
licht in das dickicht des regenwaldes zu
bringen über ihre kultur aufzuklären
damit sie überlebt
angefangen hat alles mit diesem video in
dem sie eine lebende käfer lage ist der
stecken sie in den mund beißen ab und
den kopf schmeißen wir weg
einblicke in das leben eines indigenen
volkes die den meisten bisher verwehrt
blieben gregor lebt in einem kleinen
dorf im regenwald nur eine stunde
flussaufwärts von der metropole manaus
und doch in einer anderen welt mit ihrer
elfköpfigen familie teilt sie sich eine
hütte
alleine schlafen könnte ich nicht wenn
ich in einem appartement allein wäre
würde ich meine familie und freunde sehr
vermissen weil wir immer zusammen sind
wir essen auch immer zusammen
das handy ist immer dabei aufmerksamkeit
ist die währung die zählt im netz und
gregor sitzt sie gezielt ein für sie
geht es um nichts geringeres als die
zukunft der indigenen völker
die indigenen völker werden oft gering
geschätzt
wenn man aber zu wenig über uns weiß
dann ist es auch möglich dass die leute
in unser land eindringen und uns von
hier vertreiben
[Musik]
seit dem amtsantritt von präsident ben
ali hat der raubbau am regenwald massiv
zugenommen volvo hat der mächtigen agrar
und bergbau lobby versprechungen gemacht
systematisch schlechter die
umweltbehörden kurz mittel und personal
lockert gesetze seitdem nehme nicht nur
abholzung und brände zu in den tiefen
des waldes häufen sich gewalttätige
konfrontation zwischen holzfällern und
indigenen diese bilder sind schon älter
in letzter zeit haben die gefechte noch
zugenommen allein im letzten jahr wurden
mehr als 180 indigene ermordet weil sie
ihre gebiete verteidigen wollten in
manchen regionen in denen früher
regenwald stand bleiben oft nur noch die
indigenen schutzgebiete vom kahlschlag
verschont
der widerstand gerade der jungen
indigenen wächst immer wieder
demonstrieren sie in der hauptstadt
brasilia lautstark und doch weitgehend
ignoriert von den mächtigen verloren in
einer wüste aus stein und beton stunden
lang tanzen und singen sie vor dem
präsidentenpalast vor bolt szenario weg
mit ball zur nahrung
[Musik]
den präsidenten sehen sie als gefahr für
ihre existenz nicht nur weil er den wald
zerstört es fehle ihm an jeglichen
respekt für ihre kultur
für uns ist die natur heilig der fluss
ist heilig der wald ist heilig unserer
mutter erde ist heilig denn sie gibt uns
nahrung wir pflanzen und sie gibt uns
zurück wenn wir in den wald gehen spüren
wir den frieden und wir hören die vögel
singen
auch jessica ist oft instagram aktiv um
ihre kultur zu zeigen und ihre so andere
sicht auf brasilien ihr land in dem die
indigenen völker zuerst war
wir benutzen die kommunikationsmedien
der weißen weil sie auch für uns eine
waffe sind indigene protestaktionen wie
diese werden oft ignoriert von den
traditionellen brasilianischen medien
stattdessen berichten die indigenen
influenza eine der bekanntesten ist
alicia tasche sie ist vor allem auf
twitter und instagram aktiv und erreicht
zehntausende von menschen
das internet war nie für indigene völker
gedacht aber es kann als raum der
reflexion und aufklärung dienen den
benutzen können
alice sie zeigt nicht nur ihren alltag
als indigene frau vor allem auf twitter
wird sie politisch sie zeigt die
zerstörung der natur und wie viele
influenza verbindet sie professionelle
fotos mit botschaften präsident paul
szenario wirft sie völkermord an den
indigenen vor weil seine politik
keinerlei rücksicht nehmen die
gesellschaft verfolgt eine falsche idee
von fortschritt geht es nur um
fortschritt für die wirtschaft oder für
die ganze gesellschaft wir reden von
wirtschaft von landwirtschaft von
monokulturen aber nicht vom leben vom
widerstand und der existenz der
indigenen völker
zurück beim amazonas gemeinsam mit ihrem
bruder peko geht sie in den wald zeit
für einen neuen beitrag auf instagram
wir zeigen wie wir uns um die natur
kümmern und sie schützen
doch die zeiten haben sich geändert in
den wäldern brasiliens die holzfäller
kommen näher
[Musik]
wir haben angst wenn wir in den wald
gehen hören wir den lärm oft haben sie
nicht nur motorsägen sondern auch andere
waffen dabei wenn wir dann hingehen und
uns beschweren und sagen dass sie
aufhören sollen bäume zu fällen können
sie uns erschießen um das zu vermeiden
bleibt uns nur zuzuschauen und zu
trauern dass das passiert
die leitung über die das internet ihr
dorf erreicht fällt oft aus dann wird es
wieder ein bisschen ruhiger bei den
tattoo you doch egal weiß zu viel ruhe
ist inzwischen gefährlich die welt da
draußen muss wissen was los ist in den
tiefen des regenwaldes bevor es für die
indigenen völker brasiliens zu spät ist
[Musik]